you're very comfortable very comfortable
in your sexuality so much so that you
are of often I've been around you you
will compliment the male form the male
form I love it and in fact I mostly love
looking at Brad Pitt in movies with his
shirt off and I won't this is sincerely
I'll go to a Brad Pitt's film and about
midway through if he doesn't have his
top off I start getting agitated like
alright man any time now you could be
having this same conversation with your
shirt off yeah this cuz you're at the
doctor's office for a funeral
I've seen people with their shirts off
at Pizza Hut get rid of it
we're dragging a car just say it's hot
then what are you like what do you like
if you're saying a gym and men are
undressing are you oh I'm all eyes is
that the same not all piers but all i
what are you obsessed with other areas
of the male body look I don't want to
touch a penis
well sure take a look at it you know I
want to know it's I think it's just safe
to be aware of it cuz yeah if you're
ready how is it safety I'm gonna tell
you yeah if you're at a Equinox or a
Bally's fitness or wherever you're at
sure and you'll catch a guy out of the
corner ride that's like ten inches
flaccid yeah you got to respect his
dominance like if stuff hits the fan
probably that guy should be in charge
no just flaccid you don't want him
anywhere near a fan
this is why I trained of your mind are
you think evolutionarily there's
something to be open you should be aware
of it I don't attack a man with a larger
penis that's my point is you don't want
to lip off to the if like you know you
notice the day before oh that guy's got
a baseball bat yeah and then you knock
over his water at the elliptical machine
or the Stairmaster you just be quick to
say sorry right you say my apologies
larger penis and if we raid the
neighboring village you take Italy yeah
that can't be apologizing to guys with
giant penises I just did say it would
take up your whole day
[Applause]
[Laughter]
[Applause]
you